[موسيقى]
تم بناء معظم الكاتدرائيات
لتحمل اختبار الزمن ، ولكن هذا ليس
مرحبًا به في أقواس عيد الفصح في صقلية
بإيطاليا ، ولكن تعال سريعًا
حيث لم تضيع
[موسيقى] في
كل عيد فصح تعتبر مدينة سان فياجيو في
صقلية موطنًا  كاتدرائية مصنوعة
من الخبز والحبوب والباستا
يمكن للزوار التجول عبر
أقواس الخبز والاستمتاع
بالتصاميم التفصيلية عن قرب
من قبل السكان المحليين ويستغرق
بناء أصول هذا
التقليد حوالي ثلاثة أشهر إلى العصور القديمة
عندما  زيارة أفراد العائلة المالكة المتوقع أن يتم
الترحيب بهم بعروض كبيرة ،
كانت سان بياجيو مدينة للمزارعين الفقراء الرحمة ، لذا فقد
استخدموا ما قاموا بتربيته في منتصف
القرن الثامن عشر وأصبح التقليد
احتفالًا بعيد الفصح على الرغم من أن
العروض الشهية ليست صالحة للأكل أثناء السير
عبر الأقواس  الخبز
شهادة على تاريخ المدينة الطويل
والقدرات الفنية لمواطنيها
[موسيقى]